so we're going to do a quick
introduction to reverse engineering
although this is not going to be quick
since i've got a couple hours here but
um we are going to see if i can turn
that on
and yes yay we are going to talk about
what reverse engineering is
we will also discuss a little bit about
why you would do such a thing
some of the hardware and software tools
that we'll use in the reverse
engineering process
some of the impediments that various
manufacturers will throw up there to try
and slow you down
and the general process for being able
to hack into hardware
and then hacking into software as the
case may be
and we'll actually finish up with a kind
of a brief discussion
of some protocol hacking that we did
definitely an interesting problem set
and we'll get into all of that as we go
through the material here
one of the big issues though is knowing
when to declare
victory it is always a tough thing
in doing reverse engineering you're not
quite sure when you've done enough
there's always something
else you could potentially do and it's
really a question of when you know
uh to declare victory fold up your tent
and go home
and then of course we'll finish up a
little bit of where should you go from
here all right so what exactly
is the reverse engineering process first
of all
uh let's assume we're given a piece of
hardware or software as the case may be
we want to deconstruct it we want to
find out how it was put together we want
to find out
how they built it what kinds of things
are inside of it
whether or not we can extend it and a
few other issues we'll get into as we go
through the material
now this will typically entail removing
the case
repopulating connectors disassembling
the software
and it may require the use of hardware
debuggers we'll talk a little bit about
that as well
and some other test equipment to figure
out exactly what kind of connector we're
actually looking at here on the
motherboard
but i will put this out there and make
sure especially for you at home
don't do this at home unless
you know it's legal in your jurisdiction
uh here in the united states we have
this nasty thing called the digital
millennium copyright act
and the dcma gets really testy about
disassembling firmware
so don't do that unless you have
somebody's written permission
hopefully a law enforcement agency now
that being said as we go through the
material here we will be
talking about some techniques that in
certain jurisdictions will get you
arrested
don't do them i am not going to come
bail you out of jail
and you can point to the youtube video
all you want that's not going to do
anything for you
this is the same sort of thing that i
can explain how to make a silencer
but if i make a silencer that's illegal
i will explain to you how to do reverse
engineering
but actually doing the reverse
engineering may be illegal
in your jurisdiction please make sure
you check that first
all right so why do reverse engineering
well part of the goal may be to repair
or repurpose or upgrade a particular
piece of hardware that you may have or
maybe you're just curious what's inside
the box
those of us who back in the dark ages
used to take
televisions apart and radios and things
of that sort just to see what was inside
of them much to our parents dismay
uh it was definitely something fun to do
and only occasionally after actually
after it only took once
when you get across the anode of the
television set and you get lit up by 35
000 volts you only have to do that once
before you respect that red wire
don't touch the red wire
now uh often uh and of course
part of this now is we're starting to
see some ground being gained by the
repair movement
the repair movement is a great thing uh
we should be able to repair those
devices especially
phones if going to spend 600 700 dollars
for a phone
and the battery goes dead i'm
sorry i am not going to buy a new phone
simply because the battery can't be
replaced inside of the phone
we'll figure out a way to get in the
phone and replace the battery and we'll
do all of that
again within the limits of whatever our
jurisdiction may be
there are going to be cases now this is
something interesting and we found this
happening more and more often it's
referred to as
archaeology now whether
it is because somebody made a device and
when they made the device
they lost the engineer that made the
device
they left they forgot to document it
the documentation was in a package that
was installed on a server and the server
went buns up and they can't get to the
package anymore
or same thing happens with software um
i've
had cases where they need to figure out
what the software that they wrote
actually does and it's oftentimes many
years
after the development of the software
and nobody remembers exactly what
they did or how they did it and it's not
documented and all those
happy things those are all reasons why
you might have to go in
and take a look at an existing device to
figure out what it does
and how it works now the other
possibility
is you might be presented with a
suspicious device
let's assume something fell off a truck
and showed up at your back door
well what are you going to do with that
device you're certainly not going to
plug it into your own network i hope
you never can tell now in this
particular case actually that picture
that you see
right over there that hot spot right
there
that's an actual chip under another chip
motherboard was specially modified by
somebody
that happened to come as a commercial
device and when we popped open the box
and started looking at it in an infrared
we said wait a minute
this chip's a lot hotter than it's
supposed to be i wonder what's here
and you start taking a look at it and it
turned out somebody had actually
hogged out a small space underneath the
existing part
and put something special there
now obviously that kind of thing
shouldn't happen all that often
but it does and we're actually starting
to see quite a bit more
in the way of counterfeit equipment
coming out of certain locations in
asia this counterfeit equipment some of
it is really interesting you'll look at
the real part and it has
silver solder leads and the counterfeit
part has
copper solder leads and it's the only
visible sign that you have that it's
actually a counterfeit
these kinds of things are starting to
happen more and more uh
general rule of thumb never buy
anything off of ebay that you think is
going to go into your corporate
infrastructure
just a suggestion now
uh there may also be some special
software on a device that you're
concerned about
whether that's malware spyware or
govwere
uh if you happen to be now what's gov
where gov ware happens to be something
that we find
in the german-speaking countries the
swiss have
megapanzer and the german government has
one called r2d2
and these are legitimate pieces of
software
that the government installs on your
machine when you're
asleep and at that point in time they
are key loggers and other things that
they track you and see what you do and
if you've been talking to people you're
not supposed to talk to they will come
knocking on your door
and gsg-9 is very unfriendly with the
mp5s as they kick in the door as a
general rule
don't do that that would be bad but
gubware is certainly a thing
we have actually found one special thing
that i can share with you there was
a set of equipment from a large
manufacturer of equipment of computers
and this particular large manufacturer
had sold a whole bunch of computers
to a defense contractor and the defense
contractor as part of their normal
modus operandi take the equipment and
put it into
a sandbox they basically put it into a
small
isolated network enclave and then they
start dorking around with time
and sure enough after about
six months of time it beaconed out
and went back home to china and said
hello they of course asked the
manufacturer
what was that the manufacturer said
oh it came from the original design
manufacturer that way
so the fact that they were actually
subbing the work out to a place in china
that was doing all the biases and
everything
it was a weird situation we actually
tracked it down a little bit further
than that
and what it turned out was they were
using the system management mode
on the x86 and in system management mode
it's built specifically to allow you to
take a look at
you know temperature and power rails and
things of that sort it's made for the
server world
it's a non-maskable interrupt so you
can't turn it off
and what was happening if you switched
into system management mode
there was a tcp stack in there and
it was phoning home so
little things like that yeah yeah you
should probably keep an eye on them
i always am suspicious of any new
equipment that i get
but i tend to be paranoid anyway at
least that's what my wife will say
all right so what kind of tools should
you have
in order to be able to just simply
disassemble the device
first of all you're going to need a torx
driver set torx is one of the more you
know
popular weird screws that are used in a
lot of these cases
but you'll need screwdrivers of various
sizes a precision utility knife
not to use the trade name that you all
know
exactly i mean so we don't want to do
that
but a precision utility knife
spudgers these are basically little pry
bars plastic pry bars
guitar picks work really well suction
cups
small hex drivers
thankfully thanks to the right to repair
movement these are all available as a
kit
you can go to ifixit.com and you can get
that little kit that you see there
in the upper uh right hand corner that
little thing right there
um that is a really incredible thing now
one of the things that you
don't really probably can't recognize is
that little black thing that looks like
a hot dog
about that length that's a really cool
device
that is a piece of it's a f
you know a squishy it's a squishy slug
like thing
you put it in a microwave for about 30
seconds and it heats it up
and then you slam it on the bat well you
don't slam it but you place it
on the back of the device you're trying
to unglue
and what it does is it transfers enough
heat
to the glue to soften it so that you can
then
pull the back off of machines off of
devices like
i don't know iphones that uh you're not
supposed to pull the back off of
and that's also where the suction cups
come in by the way you use suction cup
to
pull it apart those are all things that
definitely handy to have another thing
that you can do of course if you happen
to have something that you know
has an adhesive in it of some sort heat
guns
if you happen to have solder equipment
and you've got a heat gun that'll work
blow dryers if you don't happen to have
a heat gun
or this microwavable gel uh you'll heat
the adhesive up and then that will make
it
pliable enough that you can get the back
that you can actually get the box open
another thing that's really handy and
this is one of those things that you
don't really realize
until you get into the business and that
is an inspection microscope
you really need to be able to read those
teeny tiny little letters
on certain parts and even with uh
even with my bad eyes with three or four
x
magnification i still can't read them so
these little inspection microscopes
they're usb powered you can actually use
them to take pictures
of things so if you need to prove to
somebody that it was a particular part
you can actually take a picture of it
and they go up to 600 power
magnification
so it does a really nice job and
definitely
it's handy to have one of these things
around now
electrical test equipment especially
when we're trying to figure out exactly
what kind of circuits are in the box
and what voltages they're running a volt
ohm meter is a must
don't scrimp on these spend a little bit
of money get a decent one
they'll typically cost you a really good
one will cost you anywhere from 70 to
150 dollars
the one that you used to get at the old
radio shack for those of you who are old
enough to remember radio shack
the nine dollar meter yeah no that one
doesn't work very well
i still have some of those and um you
know i just use them to tease my
robotics students
here try this oh what's this meter
what's this it was a little
you know it's got a little needle on it
how do i redo it
uh the problem
with lcd based meters
is oftentimes the event that i'm looking
for happens
so quickly that it can't update the
screen
fast enough so there's a voltage
change there but it's so quick that i
can't tell what the voltage change was
if that is the case and oftentimes it is
then we drop to a digital storage
oscilloscope
now if you're a software person go into
your hardware developer one day and ask
to hook up the digital storage
oscilloscope
and he will look at you like you have
two heads and why do you even know what
one of these things is
let alone want to hook it up to
something
um a dso is a really handy application
we'll see a couple of pictures of uh
where i use the dso to take a look at a
signal and
uh it turns out that yeah you can spend
a lot of money on these things i mean
tech's got some wonderful scopes uh you
know a four channel
two gigahertz scope that'll set you back
thirty thousand dollars
uh but the reality is 50 to 100
megahertz
is good enough for most applications
most of these kind of applications at
least
so that means you can probably pick up a
couple hundred dollar scope
and it'll do okay now some of the little
pc scopes that are usb
powered some of them are not quite fast
enough because they're only in like the
5 megahertz 10 megahertz range
um usually 50 megahertz or so will allow
you to catch
most things that might be of interest
another little gizmo that's handy to
have is an 8 or 16 channel logic
analyzer
this one is one of the ones that is
powered with usb
this is my saily i've got uh a wonderful
i love my saily
uh it is a usb 3 i've got the salee pro
version so it's got a usb 3 interface on
it
when you got to transfer a lot of data
really really quick
usb 2 doesn't cut it but usb 3 does a
great job
now another thing that's handy is a sig
rock
compatible signal identification
interface aka
bus pirate or something similar these
are often we'll use these as a way of
just being able to try and identify the
type of signal that it is
is it a j tag is it a serial port is it
an i squared c
what is it because if you start plugging
things in without really knowing what it
is you'll
likely let the magic blue smoke escape
and that's bad
not to mention the fact they come in and
go why does that smell
no i took a shower it's not me it's that
thing
okay now logic analyzers is protocol
decoders
most of the high-end logic analyzers
these days
have got protocol decode in them they've
got i squared c
spy can bus asynchronous serial etc
the tricky part of course is just
identifying the signals
also these devices tend to have their
own limitation as to what kind of power
you can put across them
5 volts is a maximum and we have seen 12
volt
compatible rs232 interfaces
so the old rs232 standard actually used
to go to 12 volts
and you'll find the equipment sometimes
it still does so
definitely you got to watch out for
things like that
and some of the really expensive units
of these
will decode both pci express and other
high-speed buses
this particular one this happens to
actually be from isely um the saily
will do um 10 mega samples per second or
something like that
so it's it's fast enough fast enough for
most things
now i have a couple patents on doing
video backup
out of your video port back in the dark
ages we used to do things like that
and um i had to use high-speed echo
logic to do that so two gigahertz logic
analyzers and scopes where the
empty mainframe of the logic analyzer
nothing in it just the mainframe is 35
000
so fortunately you don't have to have
anywhere near that kind of
investment in order to be able to do
this uh by the way the sale the eight
uh port sale i think is 495 dollars
something like that it's relatively
inexpensive for what it is
uh maybe that's the 16 is the 495 the
eight may be a little bit cheaper i
don't remember right off hand it's been
a while since i bought mine
okay so now now that we got all these
tools collected
now what's the thing that we want to do
first of all we need to do a little bit
of research
we need to find out is there an original
design manufacturer someplace an odm
and if there is an odm who is it
for instance with uh laptops it's free
it's common to find
uh laptops made by a company called
clevo uh they'll be branded with
dell or hp or some other badge on the
outside of them but they're actually
made
by clevo why is that important
well it's because you're looking for the
fcc id
if you look in the device you will find
somewhere
an fcc id associated with it now the
federal communications commission here
in the united states
has requirements for any device that
could potentially
emanate in the in the spectrum when
they're doing a certification for a
class b
or class c type device they will have an
fcc id associated
with them the fcc id is
you can look it up on fccid.io
among other places you can actually go
to the fcc but it's so hard to find it
there
but there are other websites you can
actually look up the fcc id
the advantage of finding the fcc id is
that you will find
that a lot of devices use the exact same
components
in particular radios radios i actually
talked to a manufacturer
a chinese manufacturer one time about
what would it what
where's the break-even point for being
able to make my own radio
at what point does it make sense to do
that and they go well
after fcc certification and all the
stuff the registration and everything
you have to go through
breakeven point is about a million units
for your own radio so what happens
many manufacturers don't use their own
radios
manufacturers will go to a manufa to
another vendor
that has an already approved radio set
and this already approved radio set has
an fcc id
associated with it you look up the fcc
id and you find out it's the exact same
radio that's being used in like 10 other
devices
that's an advantage because one of those
other devices may not necessarily be as
locked down as the one you're looking at
it may actually have more open source
code associated with it there may
actually be some
u-boot versions and things of that sort
floating around for the other units
that you can then look at those and try
to figure out what does that mean to me
for this device that i'm having a look
at
another one which is kind of an odd one
that you wouldn't normally think about
and that is are there patents involved
does the manufacturer of this particular
device have any patents associated with
it
patents are a wonderful thing when you
go to the u.s patent and trade office or
you go
to the eu patent and trade offices
you can the patents are public record
and when you
bring up the data sheet of the packet of
the patent you will find
all kinds of interesting stuff in there
circuit diagrams
box layouts which parts are being used
for which motherboards
there's all kinds of really cool stuff
in patents
and another one that you want to take a
look at is who are the
patent holders and see if you can find
out any information about them
the reason i say that is because when we
get into the
the disassembly of the protocol we'll
find
out that it was something specific to
the patent holder
that actually made its way into the
protocol interesting problem with that
so patents and a lot of people who are
just starting to do reverse engineering
forget to check the fcc ids and forget
to check the patents
both of those are tremendous sources of
information
all right so now opening the case just
opening the case can be a problem
sometimes manufacturers will actually
sonically
weld the case and if they sonically weld
the case getting into it is a dremel
that's one of those tools that i didn't
mention before but sometimes it's handy
to have a dremel just to
cut through the case uh now
what why do they make it so hard well
sometimes they
don't want you to see all the goodness
that's inside in other cases they don't
want you to see all the badness that's
inside like that one right up there
that is probably one of the worst solder
jobs i have ever seen
in a commercial device and that's
actually considerably cleaned up over
the first two versions that they made
cold solder joints i mean it was just
horrendous inside and you just go well
if nothing else i might just fix it just
while i'm here because i just
i can't stand to look at such bad solder
joints
all right other techniques that are
designed to keep the casual user out of
their hardware
one is special screws um
we see there a picture of the pentalobe
screw
that was one that apple made that would
keep you out of the iphones
uh turned out there were only two
pentalobe screws in the iphone it was in
the base where the
usb connector was um but it was a
special screw that they had custom made
and it took at least two weeks to
fab one out of a 3d printed material
um so you know usually
you'll see torques torx screws are very
popular
make sure you have a complete set of
torques especially the little tiny
torques
they are really tough to get a hold of
and
used a lot there is a secure torx
which has a little post in the middle of
it that keeps a normal torx screwdriver
from going into it
so if you go to uh you know a fry's or
you go to
um not so much best buy but
micro center some of those places
they'll actually have
security tool kits that have all these
weird little
screwdrivers inside of them definitely
worth the 10 bucks that it costs to buy
one of those
the the tools themselves are not all
that fantastic but
when you need something that's got a
secure torx you need it
you need it then and not have to go try
and find it
yeah yeah yeah they absolutely they are
now uh of course
sometimes they'll use special adhesives
uh that was what we were talking about
earlier when you use the heat gun to
kind of melt the adhesive down a little
bit to make it a little more pliable
anti-tamper sensors now anti-tamper
sensors are really tricky
what they'll have is a case that has
some special switches inside of it
that if you open the case it triggers
the switch and
zeros out the flash um
that is particularly troublesome uh
we'll talk more about that in just a
minute
uh and the other trick that they
they do is encasing the device in epoxy
otherwise known as potting the device uh
that's that black
glue gui thing that you see right there
and they do that for several different
reasons one of them is to keep you from
figuring out what the circuit is
other times it's to keep you from keep
it from getting wet
if it is going to be in a in a moist
environment we'll want to keep the
circuitry
dry so they'll do an epoxy coat like
this
or if you happen to be going into space
it's called conformal coating
and it'll keep your devices from
outgassing
we do a lot of work in the space world
so it turns out that that happens quite
a bit
so you have to basically conformal coat
it in order to get it to
you know keep it from outgassing and
then blowing the chips up
now dealing specifically with antis
tamper switches and potting
any well-equipped reverse engineering
shop will have an x-ray inspection
capability
so it's an x-ray machine and basically
you just simply put the device under the
x-ray and you take a look at it
see what it looks like in the x-ray
world uh that will typically let you
know that there may in fact be some
tamper switches inside of it uh one of
the things we have found
with tamper switches is liquid nitrogen
does a great job at slowing them down
you hit it with liquid nitrogen through
the case and then you pull the top off
and the switch is now basically frozen
you can now put tape on it and the
switch won't trigger
so liquid nitrogen great to have around
not only that but it's fun to play with
and you can make great ice cream with it
when you
are when you're bored
now potting comes in several different
varieties including
special polyesters and epoxy resins
when you get to the potting you can
actually kind of put your finger in it
you can determine whether it's a hard
pot or a soft
and depending on the type of material
that it's made from
oftentimes heating will make it pliable
so
this is one of those cases where just
putting it in an oven
at about 200 250 degrees fahrenheit
will make the potting pliable enough
that you can actually pry it off
now um be careful with this
because as you heat this thing up first
of all understand that you're using
most likely today you're using rojas
solder so rojas solder
is a new type of solder it's lead free
but the melting point of rojas solder is
around
700 degrees fahrenheit or so
so you can heat the board up to about
250 degrees fahrenheit
and it's not going to have any damage to
the
the actual solder in there
the other thing that you may find is of
course when you do that heat
make sure you have it well ventilated
because some of these epoxies
have toxic fumes that come out of them
when they start heating up
so definitely watch out for that there
are solvents
that will often do this wd-40 actually
does a pretty good job against several
different types of epoxies
dichloromethane nitric or sulfuric acid
isopropanol all of those are types of
materials that can be used to dissolve
potting
the problem with a lot of this stuff is
it may
require special permits in your
jurisdiction
you can't just simply call up and say
hey i'd like to get a gallon of sulfuric
acid
um they most of the chemical supply
manufacturers take
a dim view of that sort of thing and
start asking a lot of questions
why do you want sulfuric acid and what
are you planning on doing with the
sulfuric acid
and when you start trying to explain to
them that you're reverse engineering a
piece of government equipment they then
take a dim view
of that and they don't sip you the they
don't ship it to you
but nitric acid certainly is something
you can typically get your hands on
sulfuric is a little bit harder
this stuff that you see there called
attack
that is actually a pretty decent
material
it's not cheap that little uh leader can
there
is almost a hundred dollars
but when you need it you need it and
it'll actually do a really nice job of
pretty much dissolving
the material now when all else fails
you go to cut and scrape cut and scrape
is a dremel
and a an x-acto knife excuse me a
precision utility knife
and it's not pretty
you see an example of it down there cut
and scrape but
unfortunately if you can't get the epoxy
to melt any other way you may not have a
choice
and of course be careful as you're using
the dremel to
scrape off you know sand off layers
because sometimes it produces fumes
sometimes the
little particulate matter if it gets
into your lungs is really bad
stuff so make sure you wear a mask when
you're doing this kind of stuff
in general anytime you're messing around
with epoxies and polyester
resins you want to wear a mask it's
really
pretty much generally nasty stuff all
the way around
now let's assume that we have managed to
get ourselves
into the device now that you got it out
of the case
let's take a look at the device to see
if you can identify the parts
oftentimes if you look at the parts
some cases they actually i've had
manufacturers
black out the part number with
you know a sharpie other cases and if
you hit it with just the right light
especially
if you're in different modalities like
infrared you can usually read it even
though they've marked it out with a
sharpie
or if you uh i have seen them actually
scrape the part numbers off to try and
keep you from figuring it out
and again in that case a little bit of
nitric acid
will usually bring the part number back
up so you can figure out what it was
that's you know so being able to read
the part numbers is easier said than
done
but if you can't identify the part
numbers try to get a hold of the data
sheets
in some cases the manufacturers will be
more than happy to give you the data
sheet mar-vell will give you a data
sheet or
atmel or one of those guys i'll give you
a data sheet others
not so keen on giving data sheets intel
for instance anybody from intel in here
i'm sorry
um intel if you want to get data sheets
from intel it requires your first born
child and you then have this book that
is
basically handcuffed to you and you
can't go anywhere
you can't leave the book because the
book gets lonely and
you know you have to carry it with you
all the time it really is kind of a
nuisance
in some of the cases for some of their
parts
but absolutely take advantage of tear
down sites like ifixit
they have already done if they've
already done the tear down for you
that's fantastic saves you a lot of time
and effort
in some cases they'll even identify some
of the really weird chips
you know it's a samsung part that's not
commercially available
it's only available for company xyz
and they'll give you a little bit of
more of additional information about it
so that's really handy if you can get a
hold of that
now getting that sample data sheet is
important
and the reason it's important is because
it'll tell you capabilities of the part
of the major chips that you may need to
know
for instance in this particular case we
were doing a work
we were doing a job that used an avr uh
it had an
18 megaprocessor in it and uh the fact
that we were able to take a look at the
data sheets and find out that there were
actually two serial ports involved in
that particular part
we then could figure out a little bit
more about what the serial ports were
doing
uh what they were up to with them
additionally they may well they may
very well talk about spy flash
interfaces and things of that sort to
give you an idea of how the board is
supposed to
supposed to boot and then if it's a spy
flash we can then hook onto the spy
flash and try to read the flash directly
but more importantly it gives you some
information about voltage
levels logic voltage levels we see today
we don't see much in the way of 5 volt
anymore it's usually 3.3 volt or even
all the way down to 1.8 or 1.2 volt
logic so you definitely need to do a
little bit of homework there
because if you try to plug in a 5 volt
rs-232 port into a 3.3 volt
logic level port it'll toast it
so definitely a bad thing data sheets
may also
outline a lot of information about the
algorithms that the part supports
if it supports things like crcs or
anything
special that may be built into the
hardware sometimes the manufacturers
will take advantage of that
and it will explain a lot of what you're
seeing when you're looking at it on the
oscilloscope
all right so now repopulating the
interfaces
of course a lot of manufacturers will
depopulate the debug in the serial
interfaces
so the um jtag interfaces in particular
will be depopulated at a minimum
sometimes you'll find the serial ports
are depopulated as well
jtag interfaces often have a pretty
familiar look about them
so it'll be a 10 pin or a 14 pin or a 20
pin connector
those kinds of things kind of stick out
on the board
and they're fairly easy to find also
again kind of a caution here about the
the logic voltage levels
in this particular case we put this
scope on it
if you use a digital signal a storage
oscilloscope
digital storage oscilloscope we have
high voltage probes that are available
for that
so when you put that on the circuit and
you're taking a look at it you know
you're not going to toast the scope
and the scope is made to be able to
sample the the voltage level so we'll be
able to see it in this particular case
for this one
this is actually looking at a
communications channel
and uh what you're seeing there are ones
and zeros going across
and also because of what what it looks
like if you actually could see it very
well you'd see that that is three
a little bit over three one volt
markings so we were looking at 3.3 volt
logic in this particular case
uh also of course a signal tester like
bus pirate
uh can oftentimes determine what kind of
signal it is whether it's a serial port
or a j tag or something along those
lines
they actually have some pretty decent
tutorials for
bus pirates and similar sorts of devices
and of course sigroc.org
is a great site for kind of information
about how to do this kind of signal
analysis
of course for those of us who do board
ports
where we're trying to port linux or
vxworks or some other operating system
to a new platform we need these kinds of
things because we need to be able to see
what the circuits are actually doing
and whether or not our our code is
actually doing what it's supposed to do
so definitely really handy to have this
kind of stuff
now other cases we'll actually see
a lot of examples here's some examples
of devices that have had to be
repopulated
that's a router up there and it turns
out that they had
four pins normally for
a serial port you'll have transmit
receiving ground so that's three pins
occasionally you will find a power pin
sitting next to it
so again this is one of those okay make
sure you test the pens
before you start plugging anything in to
know which one is the power and which
one is the ground
uarts serials jtags i mean here we see
this particular one over here happens to
be a jtag signal
we have another serial port in here this
is the pocket beagle
if you look on the back of the pocket
beagle they actually have a jtag
interface there
now this connector that you see
this is referred to as a needle
connector or a pogo pen connector
um the little pins that you see there
are spring loaded which is why they call
them pogo pins
and what you'll do is there are a couple
of holes
on either side and you clip this thing
in
and then it stays in contact with the
connector
so uh we see this being used a lot in
uh microcontrollers so whether it's an
arm
cortex m3 cortex m4 type microcontroller
oftentimes they will have some of these
pogo pens
additionally we're starting to see
more prevalence of serial wire debug
swd swd is basically jtag but it only
requires two pens
uh instead of 1149.1 ieee 1149.1 i think
is 1149.7
so they have a specification for this
thing generally the
serial wire debug is targeted at
microcontrollers but we're starting to
see it now on some of the larger arm
cortex a parts as well so and if we had
a requirement for serial wire output
which is basically a print line it's a
serial port
that requires just one more pin so in
three pens we can
absolutely get a basically debug
interface et cetera
now some of the manufacturers will
actually
blow the e-fuses so what the heck's an
e-fuse an e-fuse
is an electrical fuse that's on
the chip itself and when they blow the
e-fuse it basically breaks the
connection to the debugger
if they blown the e-fuses the only way
to fix those is to decap the chip
and with a laser you spot-weld the
e-fuse back in place
that clearly is not something that the
typical user has
at home because they basically have to
cut the top off the chip
and then look at it in an electron
microscope figure out where the fuse is
and
zap it and bring the fuse back so that's
not something that most people
people can do but nonetheless hopefully
you don't get to that
level now uh here we actually see two
connectors side by side
uh one of them is a 14-pin connector and
the other
is a 10-pin connector the 10-pin
connector happens to be two serial ports
the pin connectors jtag you'll also
notice that they
all the holes are nice and neatly filled
in in the wave solder
so when we get ready to repopulate the
connector we're going to have to get
through that and
actually solder the thing back in place
so that can be a little tricky
all right so now why bother repopulating
the interfaces well
of course for serial ports the goal is
to be able to watch the boot cycle
we want to know what this thing does
during the boot cycle we want to know if
it's using u-boot we want to know if
it's using
some custom home rolled boot loader
of course for jtag and serial wire debug
the goal here is to be able to read the
firmware out of the boot flash
we want to be able to grab all of the
firmware because that's going to have
some interesting binary blobs in it that
we probably want to take a look at
and we'll show you an example of what
that looks like here in a moment now
uh once you have the firmware you can
now start the reverse engineering of the
boot code
which bootloader is it using is there a
device tree blob
of course for those of you who do a lot
of work with the linux kernel
you know how important it is to get that
device tree blob if you don't have the
blob man your life is living hell
so um being able to pull the device tree
blob out of the firmwares can save you
an
a commen tremendous amount of time uh
obviously if you're trying to
upgrade the device let's say it had a 2
6 kernel on it now you want to move to
414 kernel you're going to have to have
the device drop blobs because they
started using device blobs in about the
3
10 314 time frame so in order to
move up to a significantly newer kernel
you're going to have to figure that out
for those of you who don't know what the
device tree blob is it's basically a way
of describing the motherboard
and the components that are on the
motherboard so you'll know exactly
there's
two serial ports located at this address
there is
megabytes worth of memory located at
this address there's an i squared c
there's a spy bus all that sort of
business gpios all of that will be laid
out in the device tree blob
so if you can get a hold of the device
tree blob that's a huge win
and of course which os is it using it
may not necessarily be using linux it
could be using
um vxworks or free rtos
or some other flavor out there and if
you
find out that it's using something like
linux then which version
of linux is it there's been significant
changes between the 2-6 kernel and the
4-4 kernel so
you know as a consequence knowing which
version of the kernel it was running is
a huge
thing to to be able to take into account
now the another thing is of course being
able to
repopulate the interfaces and use the
jtag to read the flash and get yourself
a hold of the binary that's all very
sexy and
wow that's incredible you were able to
do that but sometimes it's not that hard
sometimes you just go to the
manufacturer's website
and they will have updated firmware
or even old firmware if it's an older
device they'll have the firmware setting
out there
and you can download it and when you
download the firmware well okay now i
just saved myself all the trouble of
repopulating the jtags and all the sort
of business but i have the firmware
um if you do have a case for firmware
update
then download it take a look see what's
in it and
we'll show you some tools that help you
do some dissecting of that here in a
moment
um but depend depending on the vendor
you might just be able to download the
update directly
occasionally they will require you to
actually do the update through the
device
so if they're going to do it through the
device then make sure you've got your
wireshark turned on so you can capture
all the packets that go through
and reconstitute the actual firmware
image from the packets that got
transferred in order to download
it to the device a little bit trickier
to do that but
certainly if you are dedicated it's not
that hard
all right so now that i have the image
uh here we have an example of this
little guy right here
this is an action tech mi424
this one happens to be i think this is a
rev
f or something rev g maybe but it's one
of them that i had laying around
the house because verizon forced me to
upgrade
and therefore i had this extra router
setting there i might as well do
something with it
and when we took a look at the firmware
we actually
found that action tech does not supply
the firmware because it was
developed specifically for verizon and
as a consequence we had to go poking
around in other places to try and find a
copy of the firmware
we finally did it actually only took us
about an hour or so to research and find
out where the firmware was
and then we downloaded the firmware uh
having the firmware now you'll notice
that this is in a weird format a dot
rmt format which is some sort of remote
format
it's a strange format doesn't correspond
to anything it's
something that's proprietary but that's
okay
because it turns out that our good
friend ben walk
and if you're not familiar with ben walk
ben walk is a great tool
for looking at binaries and kind of
walking through the binary to try and
find
out what's in it we took a look at ben
walk
and sure enough there's a u-boot header
out there
which identified the type of processor
it was
and exactly what kind of kernel
it was running then we saw a gzip
compressed data segment which is
probably going to be something like oh
you know cram fs or some other sort of
compressed file system
and then we found that there was a a
wide
a wide area network firmware interface
sitting out there
um that if we were really interested in
going a little bit further in there we
would have dug into that uh
lancom firmware interface to try and
figure out what was in there but
we'll see that we didn't really have to
get that far in order to be able to do
some interesting stuff here
now once we know
where the edges are of the different
images
now we can use a tool like dd to simply
extract
the pieces out so here's an example of
separating the pieces
out of that firmware we went out and the
first part of it of course was u-boot so
our block size is
one and we told it to skip the first 163
bytes which is
what this told us to do in the decimal
here it's 163.
so we skipped the first 163 bytes and
then
basically wrote out until we got to the
next block that incorporated all of the
u-boot stuff did the exact same thing
for the compressed file system
and of course the lancom firmware just
for completeness
uh so that now we have all three of the
pieces that are laid out
now let's start poking around inside
there because it identified itself
through ben walk as a gzip compressed
image
we simply extract it out and then g
unzip it
and see what's in it and guess what
once we did the unzip and then we did a
bin walk on that
we found gzip compressed data we found
two cram fs
file systems a whole bunch of security
certificates
we found uh crc polynomials for doing
the checks we found that it was a linux
216
2616.14 release of the kernel
when that was made that was dated back
to 2014
and we also saw some of the paths for
the actual files inside of it
we cut it off because there was a whole
bunch of stuff in there that we couldn't
make fit on
on the screen even that was a little
hard to get fit but
uh you know that was a really fortunate
find
uh where you managed to just simply by
grabbing a hold of the firmware
uh doing a little bit of poking around
in it figure out that it was a gzipped
environment
un-g-zip it and then run bin walk on it
again and you find all the good stuff
that's inside of it
so now what's the general approach to
reverse engineer a binary
well we got really lucky with the uh
mw 424 part
that firmware was just fantastic because
of the way they laid it out
most firmware is not so forgiving now
you will find
that some of the firmware from
manufacturers if you can download the
firmware
it may be encrypted uh if it's encrypted
then that represents a much more
difficult problem
sometimes it's just compressed and
oftentimes you know it's one of these
security through obscurity kind of
things they compress it
and of course they don't figure that
anybody can figure out that it's
compressed and therefore they don't know
how to decompress it
but when we take a look at it we run bin
walk
and we have it print out the entropy now
the entropy if you have an entropy close
to one
that means it's typically either
compressed or encrypted
and when you see entropy like that you
go
okay but at least it didn't start at one
there was some little piece ahead of it
that was not one
so that gives you some hope that there's
some way of being able to figure out
what's inside of it
then another tool we'll use is the
strings command
once you've compressed it and you run
strings across it you'll find
all kinds of stuff in there like this
thing here start
section rg hardware ferocion
distribution the vendor verizon the
product version
et cetera et cetera that was all in
there uh
just through looking at the strings yeah
the question is how often do we find the
manufacturer strip the strings out
uh if the manufacturer is doing the due
diligence the way they should they
should have stripped it
uh sometimes they will sometimes they
won't
and it's just catch's catch can you may
get lucky and if you get lucky
take it if you're not lucky and you get
nothing but
gobble the [ __ ] out of the strings
command it's like well okay we tried
that and that didn't pan out for us so
let's move on to the next thing
now uh the next step once you've got it
separated out a bit
then we can take another look at the
entropy after decompressing that image
we see a spike right there which is the
separation between the u-boot image
and the um the rest of the cram fs
these entropy is close to one and those
are the cram fs images
and then we see the rest of the
operating system sitting out here
so uh again if it's not
solid at one that's good uh
if it's solid at one that's a bad thing
that means they've either encrypted it
or they've got something else setting
out there that makes it look like
encrypted data once we
of course in this particular case we did
the bin walk on it we found out there
were two cram fs
images in the front we know what their
offsets are because we know what their
offsets are we can simply mount them
and take a look at them uh that's a
really nice thing about the way the
loopback
interface works in linux if we can
identify what the file system is we can
simply loop back mount it and then take
a look inside
cram fs is compressed but
not the headers so the data is
compressed but the headers are visible
so you can then look at the names of the
files
inside of cram fs when you go to squash
fs it's a little bit different
now we'll see a lot more squash fs being
used a little bit harder to do the
the dereference on but not impossible
but in this case we look we were lucky
we got cramfess and it was
uh easy to go ahead and mount it now uh
normally we then dig a little bit
further into that go ahead and mount
them and try to extract things
um we'll do that at some other time we
just don't have time to mess around with
it here in this class
all right so now let's take a closer
look at the binaries let's assume we've
managed to be able to get the binary out
of the image
what can we do with it well first of all
there are bin utils
like obj copy and objdump which will
allow
us to do a disassemble of the data if
you look at object copy excuse me object
object has the dash s option that'll
allow me to disassemble the data
so this is really useful if i know the
manufacturer
if i know it's a mips or an arm or a
power pc whatever
then i get the object dump for power pc
and i do an obs jump dash s against that
image and it will then disassemble the
image for me
understand that disassembling the image
is
useful but in some cases not
terribly enlightening unless you speak
the assembly language or the native
processor if you speak the assembly
language of the native processor then
you've got all kinds of stuff there
also understand that when you run into
something like that and you've
disassembled it
there are not going to be any nice neat
labels there's not going to be i mean
basically the
object code is stripped so you will find
a jump instruction to some
random offset or some offset from where
it is right now
a relative offset rather so when you're
in that situation
you basically have to try and create a
map of the executable
from the assembly language now this is
definitely
a long pole uh to try and go through if
you can
avoid it absolutely try to this is why
we love open source it is a wonderful
thing to be able to say well i need to
get the open source from you
and then you can do a mapping between
the open source output and the actual
executable
obviously when you're dealing with open
source you can get a hold of the
compilers
gcc is often the compiler that's used
simply because it's free
and the manufacturers don't want to have
to spend um thousand dollars for a
development environment
so it works out really well that way and
everything just comes out as normal elf
with gcc
as the primary compiler all right so now
let's assume that i have my executable
and i've taken a look at it and i go
okay this looks alright
now what can i do well i can run it
if i happen to have qmu for instance for
that particular processor architecture
then i can actually put it inside of a
qmu session and try to execute the code
using tools like s trace and ltrace we
can get a pretty good idea of what the
code is doing
what functions it's calling up in the
kernel what libraries it's trying to
call as it runs
there are some disassemblers there's the
oresi project
this one is a fairly nice disassembler
does a great job for
x8664 and it tries to
figure out exactly where the jumps are
and help you put it back together again
there are also professional tool chains
and disassemblers like ida pro
now ida pro is the
hardcore reverse engineers friend
ida pro is not cheap it's like six or
seven thousand dollars for a copy of ida
pro
per cpu architecture
so it's not cheap but
it is awesome
um what will happen you get the assembly
language output over here
you then it will construct a calling
graph for you
uh and allow you to label things so if
you look at a particular piece of
assembly language code you can clearly
tell that it's a print statement
you can actually label it as print so
when you're creating
the calling sequence here you can
actually try to figure out
what this what the calling sequences
were
what code is calling what the inner
relationships between the individual
function calls inside of it
understand this code was probably c code
or c plus code at some point and now
we're looking at the assembly language
so
a lot of the things that would have been
control structures inside of the sea
have to be mapped into assembly language
control structures
we can also see the actual data itself
down here
and in some cases we're looking for very
specific bite patterns
that indicate the end of a jpeg image
for instance if they happen to have
a um a boot logo
or a splash screen in the unit and you
want to change the splash screen to make
it really cool
well you want to find out where the
splash screen starts and where it stops
and figure out how much space you have
and whether or not you can actually go
out there and reprogram it
so all that sort of stuff comes into
play with ida pro
as i say it's not a cheap although you
can get i think a 30-day evaluation of
ida pro
if you want to play with it but they
have training classes that teach you how
to use ida pro because it is a complex
enough tool set
that you really need to take the
training class
this is used often times by larger name
government agencies
to disassemble malware and figure out
what the malware actually did
or what it's supposed to do
always use protection that's a general
statement in life
but nonetheless never run a foreign
binary on your test platform without
taking some significant precautions
first of all qmu is a good start make
sure you keep it bottled up
and of course there is support for most
of the common cpu varieties out there
especially mips
power pc arm and x86
or you can use a vm if you're if you've
got kvm certainly use that to keep the
application bottled up
at a minimum use a charute lxc type
environment
uh lxe rather than docker simply because
lxc looks like a real
operating system to the application as
it runs um
docker tends to be so stripped down the
application says well i'm missing this i
don't have this library blah blah blah
blah i can't run
uh well okay if you're running lxc
chances are you can actually
trick it into thinking it's running on a
real operating system yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah um
yeah it turns out that some malware will
look
at certain registers to find out if
they're there
and apple calls that the uefi bios
i'll probably get in trouble for that
cut that out
but they actually look for special
registers in places and if they don't
find them then they say oh i must be
running under vm and therefore i don't
run
uh so yeah there there is uh certainly
uh
legitimate pieces of code as well as
malware that will look around
inside the environment that is running
in to determine whether or not it's
running on real hardware
in that case you have to go in and dork
around with your qmu
register sets to make it think that it
looks like real hardware
sometimes easier said than done of
course
capture the run with s-trace and l-trace
we want to see what it's doing we want
to see what kernel functions it's
calling
we want to see what libraries it's
accessing um note any anomalous behavior
it could be a legitimate application and
because of
the fact that it's the third tuesday of
the month it does something weird on the
third tuesday of the month
they call that microsoft patch tuesday
and now yeah cut that out too i'm gonna
get in real trouble here all right
alternatively
you can transfer the application to a
small platform now let's say it's arm
then we can take a beaglebone or a
raspberry pi and we can
transfer the application to that
platform and try to run it there
if something goes wrong pull the plug
simple enough and uh you can always
re-format the sd card and start over
again
but if i'm running malware i probably
want to destroy the sd card
and get another one i don't want to take
any chance that there's something
left over even though you reformat
sometimes the bad block list and
everything doesn't quite work the way
you think it should
and it's also i've seen malware that
actually manipulates the bad block list
so
definitely be careful about those kinds
of things with sd cards
in general don't run with uh
internet protocol enabled don't have it
connected to the internet
uh pull ethernet cable or go into ip
tables and
block it off there block all the
outbound traffic
until you have a warm fuzzy feeling
about what it's doing
again putting it inside of a kind of a
sandbox and watching it go back and
forth
it turns out that in that case i was
talking about with the major
manufacturer and the bios chirping back
out to china
that was no operating system running
that was just sitting at the bios
and it chirped out so they call that
beaconing
and this is a characteristic of a lot of
malware it'll beacon back home
let them know hey i'm here this is my ip
address do you have anything for me to
do
and the controller will say go to sleep
and call me in a week
or a month or six months and then
it will wake up again go back out check
to see if there's anything new to do
and then things will do some really
interesting stuff this is what you call
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance operations
with isr operations we're interested in
looking
to create a map of your network
and creating a map of the network is
really valuable because it then tells me
that you have
printer x and router y and
devices made by manufacturers such and
such
and by that information it helps me
understand
what sorts of attacks might be viable
against that
so understand that the malware writers
are trying to do that against you
in which case you definitely need to be
careful with that kind of stuff
now uh we'll show you real quick here
the
an example reverse engineer of a
protocol
in some cases it's not the device that
we're really interested in
we're interested in the communications
protocol that the device uses
ethernet cabling of course just because
it's got an ethernet cable plug on it
doesn't necessarily mean it's ethernet
we see ethernet cabling those eight pin
db rj45s get repurposed
they are repurposed for serial ports
they're repurposed for all kinds of
stuff
and it may not be standard 802.11
i mean 802.23 or 8.88
i'll get it 802.3.2 it may not be
that it may be ethercat or it may be
some other industrial protocol which
happens to go across ethernet cables
so when we're trying to understand
exactly what that's doing
uh it's great to be able to uh kind of
sniff the protocol and see what's all
see what's up serial protocols
themselves are also significantly
difficult to reverse engineer
some of it is just because we're dealing
with ancient technology
and uh that very few folks still
remember what a serial port is or how to
hook it up
a lot of the deals with serial ports
today it's just a usb
connector you just plug in the usb
connector and it magically works but
uh in a lot of this older equipment we
actually have
you know data terminal ready data you
know request to send clear to send kind
of signals
that we need to understand exactly how
they work in order to enable the device
otherwise it won't work now the use of
logic analyzers with protocol decoders
is your savior here
the the big mambo daddy of all protocol
decoders is a device from agilent
it is a decoder that understands how to
do like
e2 e3 signals t1 signals
um you know telephony signaling
mechanisms
and they're expensive i mean they're you
know 20 30
dollars for one of those things uh so
if you can use some of the low end logic
analyzers like the sale units to help
you understand what's going on that's a
that's a good thing
uh saves you a lot of money now
obviously again we can't emphasize
strongly enough
check your voltages this one happens to
be the device that we were getting ready
to do the re on
and what voltage does it show 9.6 volts
now why was it running at 9.6 volts
turns out it had a pack of double a
batteries that were running it
and that's the raw voltage off the
double a's
and then it would go through various
buck transformers and step downs and
filters and everything to get it down to
the 3.3 volt that the actual circuit
used
but that meant that you had 9.6 volts
floating around in the system and you
had to be very careful about what you
plugged into
because that will definitely toast a
serial port in a hard and heartbeat
now again remember volto meter may not
necessarily do what you need it to do if
the voltage is very
quickly you may not be able to see the
spike in the voltage in which case we
have to drop back and take a look at it
through a digital storage oscilloscope
or something similar
now once we have it hooked up and we
think we've got it
at least the voltage that we're trying
to figure out then try to see if you can
get the device to send any data
and watch what happens does the voltage
change significantly
or does something else weird happen
we'll see we'll talk about this
particular one where something else
really weird happened
all right so let's capture some data
this happens to be the output from the
sailor unit
this was the transmit side this is the
receive side
so they're not lined up exactly like
that you had the transmit side and then
you had the receive side it was a half
duplex connection
um the bit width the bit width
when you actually set on and measured
these bit widths
you found that it was roughly 56
kilobits
but not exactly 56 kilobits it was
59 kilobits in some cases
so some of that has to do with they're
not using a good solid
crystal reference uh sometimes if
they're doing
uh phase lock loops and they're trying
to generate the voltage
i mean they're trying to generate the
clock using a phase lock loop sometimes
the phases have the phase lock hasn't
really happened yet
and therefore it will be a little wonky
in terms of the frequency coming out of
it
but uh it was roughly 56 kilobits and
there was some drift in it
but that was something that we could
easily take into account in the sailor
unit
now when you're trying to do a protocol
decode
if your logic analyzer supports multiple
protocols
try and switch you've captured the data
just simply switch the interpretation
if you look at it as can bus if you look
at it as i squared c
if you look at it as you know normal
rs232 async
you know those kinds of things can be
really
helpful just to be able to see it how
many pens
are involved with the signal is it
something that i can see in just two
pins in which case it's probably an
rs232
but does one of the pins look like a
clock when you hook it up to the sailing
units you're going to see this thing
going to tt
and that's probably i squared c so when
you start doing interpretation
for i squared c you'll be able to decode
the master and slave interfaces
you'll figure out what the i squared c
id is
and little tools like arduinos are
wonderful at being able to do do decode
on this kind of stuff
generate the actual i squared c clocks
the spy clocks and then be able to
get the device to talk to you even
though
it's maybe kind of isolated from the
rest of the circuitry
uh of course when we were taking a look
at that particular protocol there were
some really strange things about the
protocol
uh if you if you take a look here um
you'll notice that the
uh let me see if i can get this to show
up over here whoops wrong way
uh you'll notice that there was no
voltage over in this section
and then suddenly the voltage went high
for about 2000 milliseconds
so about two seconds and then it started
clocking data
now this looks a lot like something
called
break a mark after break so when you're
looking at mark after break protocols
there are certain types of protocols
that use this particular technique
so we were originally thinking that it
may be a mark after break protocol
then as we got a little bit further into
it it turned out that it didn't match
any of the
known mark after break protocols and
when we took a look at the data sheet it
turned out that this particular part
didn't support
mark after break communications protocol
so that helped us a lot
by being able to rule out what we knew
it wasn't
we didn't know what it was but at least
we knew it wasn't mark
after break now uh
this uh and taking a look at it because
of that weird it was off and then
suddenly it went high and then it
started clocking data
it looked a lot like it might be bit
banged and when you're bit banging the
port like that
um that would also explain a lot of
where we were getting some of the drift
in the clock frequency if you're bit
banging the porch you might be off a
little bit
in which case it might look like 56k
plus or minus a couple of k bits per
second
and so it looked like yeah maybe this is
bit bang okay well this is going to be
interesting to try and figure out what
this protocol does
fortunately there was some weird things
about the protocol that
told us that it was not quite bit banged
it turned out that of course the
voltages started at zero
and because the voltages started at zero
we looked at the part we found out that
the part had two serial ports on it
so we suspected they were using one of
the serial ports for the communications
channel but serial ports when you enable
serial ports
there's a voltage that's constantly
available on either the transmitter
receive pin depending on whether it's
connected as
dte or dce and
in taking a look at that we go okay well
that's really weird because there's no
voltage at all
for extended periods of time and then
when we trick it to do something
it the voltage suddenly comes on and it
starts clocking
uh we took a closer look at that we
found out that it was
it although it looks like a break signal
that high signal that would come out
it really wasn't mark after break and
then
we have it it meant that basically if we
wanted to inject a new command
we're going to have to figure out what
the pattern is and follow the pattern
so the goal for this particular case was
to be able to get into the
communications protocol and start
injecting
commands that
in some cases might confuse the device
in other cases might do something
special
in the device that we can't really
get into the details of all right so uh
we used a microcontroller to do a lot of
this testing
uh turns out in this particular case it
was a cc3200 from texas instruments
um the nice thing about this one is it
had the right voltage level it was all
3.3 volt
so we didn't have to do any level
shifting we didn't have to get any
special
circuitry out there to handle 3.3 to 5
volt level shifts
also this gave us wi-fi and jtag on
the embedded board so we could actually
have some options for interfacing to the
micro and then kind of watch what's
going on
we did opt in this case to use the
arduino like energia
or energia depending on how you
pronounce it i guess this looks like
arduino code and it sits on top of tir
toss so we can get it to do
fast things when we need them to be fast
but
not have to sit there in eclipse and our
minds go numb
as we look at the eclipse code to
basically
boot the board and do all the rest of
stuff with it so
energy was a great solution for this
particular case
now in the first try we said okay well
we think we know what we need to do we
need to inject some
serial port like stuff we
knew we wanted to isolate our circuitry
from their circuitry so they would not
know that we were there
so we basically made our equipment look
like a diode well we used a diode to
keep it from
uh being able to be detected by the
devices that we're communicating with
each other
and it turned out that if we didn't do
that
or if we used a diode but then didn't do
any additional isolation we ended up
with this weird thing
you'll notice those are not nice square
edges
that's bad that says that
we would sometimes get some things
through but other things wouldn't come
through
and it was all mystery meat until we put
the scope on it and then once we saw the
scope we go oh
that explains it um also weird thing uh
the voltage levels here instead of 3.3
volt this was 1.8 volt
so it was a little strange that we would
see some
big change in the voltage there so um
the fact that it the voltage got cut in
half the edges looked horrible
this is not a good thing we have to
figure out some other way
so uh we went to a high speed schottky
diode
and the high speed shotkey diode can
handle the frequencies
so that seemed to fix the problem for us
again because it's a diode we basically
isolated ourselves from the signal
they couldn't tell we were there we
could inject uh commands into the system
and see what happens uh we also needed
to power the microcontroller so what we
wanted to do this we wanted to have this
a box
that would basically just plug in line
with the thing that we were doing the
testing on
just to make things easy that way we
could upgrade the system
in a matter of like 20 seconds and put
our box in the middle and then start
looking at signals going back and forth
we needed to power the micro and keep
the signal
at the same reference ground this is a
tricky thing
we definitely want to make sure that the
ground being referenced in the
controller the real controller
is the same ground we're being
referencing in our circuitry
otherwise we get ground loop problems
and things just go to hell in a
handbasket
so uh what we did was remember that 9.6
volt power
we pulled the 9.6 volt power ran it
through a buck transformer that's that
little white thing you see down there
and converted it to 5 volts to power the
microcontroller
so if you powered the microcontroller
through a 5 volt
usb connector if you powered it with 3.3
volt it didn't work
at least not for our application if you
powered it with 5 volt through the usb
connector everything worked fine
so we basically took the 9.6 volts we
pulled the
power off of the connector we ran it
into this power supply we then ran the
power supply
underneath into a usb adapter which you
can get from sparkfun they're great
a little pcb that has a usb connector on
one side and just
through-hole solder pins on the other uh
and so we ran it into that and it turns
out that
these let's see whoops wrong button
these pins that you see here that's
actually the pins of the cc3200 sticking
up through this pcb
through this perf board and uh when we
did
all of that uh it was amazing we could
actually inject new commands
and uh watch what happens you know as we
were going through doing the decode on
the protocol
we actually found out that there was
some places where it was
representing um a hundred percent
so you would see a hundred percent on
one thing or a hundred percent on the
other thing
and then the mix of hundred percent so
you would end up with a hundred percent
if you added the two of them together
those are both being represented in two
bytes for each one of those
values um also now this is the thing
that we were talking about earlier where
you did a little research on the
manufacturer and the people who hold the
held the patents uh turns out that the
people who held this particular patent
were both ham radio operators
and we were looking at the protocol
output and there was a weird thing at
the end of the protocol
that was a 16-bit value that changed
drastically depending on what the input
data was
and so we've we've said okay well this
is probably
a 16-bit crc and the problem is 16-bit
crcs there's
24 different 16-bit crcs
in this particular case the because the
two
people who hold the patent were ham
radio operators we said ah
ax-25 which is a 16-bit crc that's used
in ham radio protocols let's try that
sure enough that's what it was
so i mean as a ham radio operator i go
ah you know i betcha they're using ax25
let's try that
and sure enough that's what they were
using
and when we went into when we went back
into the data sheets and
actually dug down through the data
sheets for the atmel part
um we found that ax25 was one of the
modes that it supported
so it's like ah cool so this is i mean
this is
esoteric uh you know detective work but
this is the kind of thing that you have
to do when you're trying to be serious
about reverse engineering something
now uh but with this particular solution
we were able to inject commands complete
with the crcs
and lo and behold the controller and the
device it was controlling was unaware
that we were there
and we were able to do our particular
job in this case
inject commands and make things do light
up and do
funny things now reverse engineering
kind of a summary here
reverse engineering is an incredibly
challenging problem
it we have found some weird correlations
and that is people who are really
talented
at reverse engineering also like to pick
locks
i'm not sure why but it's just a
correlation
and some of the people who make malware
they will have like
sets of locks sitting on their table and
that's what they'll do for
you know a break a mental break they'll
sit there and try and pick the lock
um i don't know why
but it just happens to be a strange
correlation there
it's a problem-solving issue and
if you like solving really really tough
problems and you're familiar enough with
the
technology the hardware underneath it
that you can then
try to figure out you know okay so this
is a serial port but it's not quite a
serial port
you know why is it doing this then
you'll be successful
make sure you gather your tools the
hardware tools from places like ifixit
again the right to repair movement is a
fabulous thing because
being able to source suction cups and
pentalobe screwdrivers is a major pain
in the butt
but thanks to ifixit we can just simply
buy it as a kit
yeah it's a couple hundred bucks for the
kit but it's worth every penny
uh understand what your goals are and
when to declare victory
is your goal just simply to figure out
oh this is a unix or this is a linux
machine
i had my wife got upset with me with
this one
we had a samsung television
and uh there was a firmware update for
the samsung television
and remarkably enough when you did the
firmware update
you saw things go across on the screen
like
you boot they go ah okay
we're running ubud on this platform and
there was a
maintenance connector on the back uh
that happened to be a serial port uh of
course the wife took a damn view what
are you doing to our tv set
stop that hands off
i'm watching that uh so
but it's it definitely is kind of a cool
thing when you understand the technology
behind a lot of what's
being built today and certainly here at
the embedded linux conference
uh many of the devices that are being
constructed are in fact using linux
anything that is an internet of things
kind of device
it's got to talk to the internet
somewhere and if it's got to have a
protocol stack protocol stacks you can
get them for microcontrollers they're
expensive
uh but if you can get a free one for
linux now okay it may be worth it to pay
a little extra more money
on the the processor side and not have
to worry about all this software that
you'd have to write in order to handle
repos and
firmware updates and dealing with uh
you know certificates and all that sort
of business
so the other thing that i would say is
understand the legal implications
of what you're doing as i say in some
jurisdictions just taking the firmware
off the platform
using a spy flash reader is illegal
definitely check that before you start
going down this path
um for most of us i mean we think well i
bought a ps3 and
because i bought a ps3 it's my ps3 and i
can do anything i want to if i want to
run linux on my ps3 i can do that
no the dcma says if i go in and change
the boot sequence the boot firmware to
boot linux instead of booting the ps3
operating system
i violated the dcma and
you know it's like well i i own it no no
you don't if you read the fine print you
really don't own it
you have a unlimited lease
on the device so always make sure you
read the fine print
now um because i i like to live
dangerously
uh what we're going to do here is i'm
going to
see if i just basically i soldered
i repopulated one of the serial ports on
this board
and we're going to try it for the first
time and of course
you know again i didn't sacrifice a
large amount to the demo gods this
morning
so i'm not sure exactly what it's going
to do
but we're going to try it anyway so
what we'll do is because i've
repopulated the serial port
and i went through and i did measure
some voltages to kind of know what what
sorts of things to expect we'll run
minicom
on this and uh we will set it up
for uh 115.2
which is usually the volt is usually the
speed that a lot of these guys work
it'll be either 115 2 or 9600 baud
those are the two that they tend to go
to now the one that we did the protocol
re on that was 56 kilobits that's a
little unusual
uh 38.4 is even more unusual but again
just by looking at the
the uh the signal we can figure out what
the bit width is and then
calculate from the bit width we can
figure out what the baud rate is
but let's assume that we have here uh
115
2 running in eight one that's the other
problem that we run into with serial
in most cases it'll be no
no parity eight data bits one stop bit
but
that's not guaranteed it could be seven
data bits uh
one uh stop bit seven data bits one stop
bit
even parity or odd parity odd parity
turned out to be one that he used a lot
in older equipment so again
kind of look at the signal as it's
coming across the scope and see if you
can figure out whether you've got start
bits and stop bits and how many of those
things you have
so let's assume that we're running here
and i'm going to go ahead
and power it up and see what happens
all right now with any luck
let's see what we get here
oh yippee skippy
so we've got uboot sitting here and we
can do a print
env
and there's all the u-boot settings so
uh we now know based on this version of
u-boot that there is no binary blob
no device tree structure because of the
way the u-boot is put together
and uh we can then tell it to let's just
go ahead and
live dangerously let's reset it
so it's uncompressing so this is coming
off of those
two cram fs protocols
here let me just blow it up a little bit
here
ethernet's running at 125 megahertz
uh wi-fi interfaces
um
let's see this one actually it turns out
that this is a mips processor
this one happens to be using a cavium
processor
and it's bringing up the ethernet at
this point
let's see if we can get it to ah there's
a user prompt
username and password i haven't gotten
to the point where i've figured out what
the username and password is yet
any questions is anyone still away
what's yes of your most tedious reverse
engineers
where it's like real-time encryption of
the os is stored on flash and you're
like
unfortunately i cannot say
yeah um both under nda
and classification issues i can't say
but it was it was really tricky it was
it was like
you incl you know implied there was some
real-time encryption happening
and uh some decryption that was going on
you had to basically
so differential power analysis has
anybody ever
seen differential power analysis so with
uh differential power analysis we can
basically monitor the power rails
and it turns out it takes more power
to decrypt a one than it does to decrypt
a zero
so if you're watching it you can
actually pull
1024-bit rsa keys off of the device
without too much trouble
now downside is you have to have
physical access to the device this is
not something i can
you know stand off a couple miles and
figure it out i have done
things where for instance back in the
day of uh
crts you used to be able to reproduce
with a good receiver
i could reproduce everything that was on
the crt from at least
from almost a mile away and so i could
watch exactly what you were doing what
you were typing
all that sort of stuff of course it was
on my screen it was an oscilloscope and
it was all in green
but i could still figure out what you
were doing and i could see the commands
you were typing and when you
entered password i could see what that
was um
that was uh back in my day when i worked
for some larger name government agencies
doing
tempest which was a way of being able to
look at emanations and try to figure out
what was going on out there
other questions yeah oh i don't answer
your questions i'm sorry
no no okay
uh a little bit have not had you know
once you pay the license it's kind of
like okay you got what you got and
you know what you got that's another
possibility
you know there are a lot of additional
tools i mean i developed some
really nice disassemblers in the past
and tools for doing analysis of code
we did have a large manufacturer
printers
asked us to reproduce a piece of code
that they had done
it was originally written in in italy
there were like 60 people who worked on
the code for three years
to develop this product and then that
division went under
and they said can you reproduce the
product based on what we have
here we have the source code the source
code
was 17 000 lines of source code
and they were actually what it was doing
is it was taking a scanned image
converting it into a pdf and then
emailing it to somebody
so it was one of those things called a
document center and um
it turned out that they were
instantiating every line
every pixel as another object
i mean this was like uh and and so you
could tell the difference between
paulo's
code and giuseppe's code
because they all had their own
particular coding styles
and uh we took a look at it i mean i
have some tools that do
you know reverse engineering of large
code bases like this
and it broke all of them it was horrible
but we said you know what we think we
know what you want us to do
let us try and we were able to reproduce
it with open source code
two people uh six weeks and we had 95
percent of the functionality working and
we knew how to solve the other five
percent and they said that's enough
we've seen enough
oh uh by the time we finished we had 50
lines
of code that was it total 50 lines of
code everything else was just
pipe this to this and do this thing and
and it was like you know it's just a
shell script basically and we could
reproduce this thing in like 50 lines of
code
and the 50 lines of code was some uh
some java that somebody wanted because
they wanted to have a display
it's like okay we'll give you a display
sure
success what do you want um and that was
that was all the code was just basically
to do the display that they wanted to
have the
success um yeah okay question um
that's a good point um you know
oftentimes
uh oh i i should have mentioned this you
always get
two of whatever device you're going to
have
i mean i guess it seems obvious but um
because
the first one you're probably going to
destroy
and then once you learn everything you
need to learn then you do the second one
but yeah you always want to make sure
that at least two of them fall off the
truck
so that you can figure out what it is
question so let's say you're on the
other
building side iot project and the point
of your boss says
we need to make this thing happen
[Laughter]
given enough time and money anything is
possible
now uh the question is how much time and
money is it going to be
uh understand that um you know when
you're dealing with typical black hats
that are going to be trying to take
things apart
their motivation is primarily money
they're trying to hack
credit card numbers or something they're
trying to get some money out of it
and if you make it sufficiently hard
they will give up and go on to a softer
target
now at what point is it sufficiently
hard well that's
up for debate uh in the case of state
sponsored
hackers they effectively have no budget
and they have the best and brightest
that they have been able to find
and there are some really clever people
that are in that business
and if you're going against state
sponsored
they will own you eventually it may take
a little while
but if they really want it they'll get
it
[Music]
absolutely you want to know who's trying
to hack your system
and unfortunately today a lot of
companies don't spend enough time doing
threat modeling
when you're trying to develop secure
code and that's the other thing that we
do we help people understand what it
means to develop secure code
and so when you're in that particular
business
uh you're trying to explain to them that
the security engineering can cost
at least as much as the total product if
not more
if you really want to lock it down so
now your threat modeling becomes a
factor
you know we're talking about risk
mitigation here what risks do i want to
accept
what risks do i want to transfer to a
subcontractor so it'll be their problem
i'm talking to you toshiba i mean
you know toyota um you know so uh
you're going to transfer some of that
you're going to accept some of the risk
you're going to try and mitigate the
risk by adding additional security
measures in place obviously when we're
using things like tpms
and secure data stores that makes things
a little bit harder
obviously and then of course using tpms
we needed to understand which type of
tpm
because the chinese have their own tpm
that have their own encryption
algorithms in them
they do the standard tpm 1.2 stuff but
they also do something else and it turns
out that a lot of
machines a lot of laptops and things
that come out of mainland china
have the ssa has the sx88 chips in them
and that's a different kind of tpm
and then you wonder okay is there a back
door in there
but they the reason they created that
chip is because they were afraid that
tpm's from infineon and all these other
places also had backdoors in them so
go figure any other questions
yeah um
have you seen the fact that people are
trying to produce electrons cheaper
faster quicker more
hidden back doors
um occasionally uh
what we find are some really interesting
things they call them doorknock
protocols
so basically you hit this port this port
this port
in this order and it unlocks something
door knock protocols are really
interesting to see them implemented
one of the easiest ways to avoid that
kind of problem as you're trying to
engineer a secure solution
peer review i mean it sounds stupid but
having more than one person look at it
go
what the hell is that why are you doing
that
is a great thing i mean you take a look
at the numbers between proprietary code
versus open source code
proprietary code tend to have tends to
have nine times
more errors in it than open source code
does simply because if nothing else it's
because of the peer review
now that does not mean that open source
code is impervious
look at heartbleed that was a big one
and it had been in there and everybody
was using uh
ssl for five years before anybody ever
find it found it
it had been peer reviewed but they just
had didn't happen to see that
uh mostly greed um you know understand
that when you're trying to build a new
device that nobody's built before
or something that's supposed to be
better than anyone else has built before
the the market is you're either number
one
number two or nobody knows who you are
uh we can easily say okay who's the
number one book seller
on the internet amazon who's number two
barnes and noble good who's number three
maybe yeah that's that's the thing once
you get to number three
nobody knows you i mean you might as
well not even bother
so um the the problem here
is that uh time to market is everything
you know if i've got this really cool
thing and i need to get it out of the
market i need to get it out there before
anybody else does
we take shortcuts we don't do the due
diligence we don't do the security
engineering
um you know understand what's the
mindset today the mindset today is
let's say you've just bought your brand
new iphone x what's the first thing you
do you plug it in
and then it yeah well yeah the garbage
okay
i i don't i mean i've i've got uh
you know i use sony but um
tim berg would actually be happy about
that uh since he works from sony but
in any case uh the the the issue here
is the very first thing you do is you
plug it in and you update the firmware
so manufacturers know that the very
first thing you're supposed to do
is update the firmware so they ship it
with firmware that has
bukus bugs in it security problems
all kinds of stuff just to get it into
the distribution channel
once it's in the distribution channel
they figure the first thing you're going
to do when you get it home you're going
to plug it in you're going to update it
so
that gives them an extra six months you
know anywhere from three to six months
in the distribution channel
before they have to worry about anybody
actually using this really buggy
software
so that gives them an opportunity to fix
it and then
pre-position the update so that as soon
as you update your phone everything's
good
now that doesn't keep you from
jailbreaking the iphone within 24 hours
of them new coming out with a new
firmware but
that's a different problem but that's
the kind of thing and that's the mindset
that a lot of manufacturers are in these
days
uh even my uh i saw i had an oled
television set from lg
and the first thing you do is you update
the firmware when you plug the tv in
really that's something i mean most
people wouldn't think to plug in an
appliance into the internet to update
its firmware
uh now i always am suspicious about
things like that so i
kind of turn on wireshark and i watch
what it does
but that's a different story anything
else
yeah questions
yeah um there are going to be cases like
that i mean for instance
uh the the third people's liberation
army
uh which used to be the name they've
changed the name now because everybody
knows who the three pla is
um but they had a captain that had been
uh working at seagate uh in malaysia
one of their plants and every hard area
that got shipped out had something
special on the hard drive they found him
they caught him
he pulled out his black passport and
they deported him but
now we don't know how many of those hard
drives got out before they found him
so those kinds of things that's kind of
a one-off
i mean it's a very specialized system
you're not going to see it being done
very often
and so uh you know fortunately that's
been so long ago now that uh most of
those hard drives are already dead
but it's still the possibility if you
find a box
an old box not very common
uh because it's uh it's always you know
what's the payback uh
how quickly can i achieve the goal that
i'm trying to achieve
and if i gotta custom create some
whacked out thing to reverse engineer
this stuff it's just like
you know is it economically feasible if
somebody's paying me then absolutely
i'll do whatever you're telling me to do
uh not that i'm uh a bad guy or anything
but
uh you know the reality is if you're
paid to do reverse engineering that's
what you're paying to do and there are a
lot of companies out there that do
reverse engineering
now uh you know obviously you're trying
to to do the the quickest
solution uh because nobody wants to hear
that well you know it's going to take me
six months to figure out how this
protocol works especially with
encryption
encryption is really really tough uh
encryption is not the end-all be-all
because it all becomes an issue of
whether or not you can retrieve the keys
uh data in use is a real interesting
problem
uh turns out that what we see in data
centers a lot
of times as you start migrating vms from
one machine to another
they take all their memory and they
write it off to disk
so passwords keys
things like that that happen to be
sitting in memory are now on disk
and it makes it real easy to find them
[Music]
not necessarily not necessarily uh and
and this is again
to get it out quick they did a kind of
crappy job
of doing their security engineering so
you find
um weird stuff like that we have a
cyber security class we teach a cyber
security class and
in that class we actually do this we run
a vm and
we snapshot it and then you look in the
vm and you can actually find the
password
um reverse engineering is almost
always done as a
as kind of a temporary blog sort of
thing and the
sites will pop up and then disappear as
people start
getting angry with them um you know you
shouldn't have done that in my machine
i'm gonna crush you
you know that kind of stuff so
unfortunately there are some books
that are out right now on reverse
engineering in particular is a nice one
that
just came recently came out on reverse
engineering linux binaries
uh definitely an interesting one you can
pick it up on uh
kindle actually um i just i just got it
myself i'm still going through it at
this point but
um i forget right offhand send me an
email mike at the ptr group.com i'll
tell you who it is
uh okay we're out of time i appreciate
it thank you very much